the Joe Rogan experience how did that
cat coffee get found out the Kokila walk
good idea cuz I'm an [ __ ] decided to
pick catch it and find beans in it it's
a it's a cat like animal right it's
called a civet yeah you know ya ever had
that [ __ ] that Kopi Luwak coffee no it's
very expensive Tate and I got it once
when we're at a gig in Florida
Tate yeah looks like a hundred-dollar
cup of coffee or something stupid it's
really ridiculous not that much maybe
okay well remember he was bodyguards new
home yeah yeah back in the day yeah
that's the animal look at that thing so
that thing eats the coffee beans it
shits them out and then people pull it
out of the poop
it looks like the things baby like the
thing from Fantastic Four it looks like
it's baby
yeah they pull those beans out of the
poop and then they they dry them off and
make coffee out of cat [ __ ] and it
tastes delicious because what it is is
that that that's gold right there's gold
coming out of that cat's [ __ ] look at
that that is ridiculous you just see
that online taking a large look if that
was a person you'd be in jail alright if
you if you went and googled that person
[ __ ] on a log like that be like you
sick [ __ ] long as it's an animal it's
fine to look at their [ __ ] and even mine
it they mind their [ __ ] for beans
the idea is that the the digestive
enzymes from the civets body break down
the beans the coffee beans that's the
idea and you liked it it's okay
don't you wasn't better that's not bad
I'm here for the guests it's not better
the idea is that it's supposed to be
smooth
sooo this cat [ __ ] coffee smoother I
don't know man I don't necessarily think
it really is smoother it's just
different some weird [ __ ] I wonder if
you could just eat the cat [ __ ] just
like that without cleaning it off if
you're really nasty yeah a natives
probably just used to eat the cat [ __ ]
directly it probably did but I think you
need energy you probably need to boil it
that's why when you're making coffee in
that boiling water probably kills all
the bad stuff mmm
you know they blow did the Indians boil
[ __ ] no I don't know who invented that
[ __ ] and how long it's been around that
[ __ ] literally literally who invented
that coffee how long spin around spinner
I'm looking at right now Wikipedia since
like the 1800s
mmm they noticed that these particular
animals were eating specific cherries or
whatever that they were leaving around
and that they were going undigested so
at some point they decided to clean it
off and see how it tasted I guess that
makes sense
[ __ ] risk